hello Internet it's me Greg and I'm back
with more color magic know my last video
that you can watch right here
I shared a fun color experiment that was
designed to help you create color
palettes of your own entirely from
scratch but in this video I'm going to
show you how to use that welcome to how
to use color palettes and be pretty good
at it most of the time the video in the
right hands a color palette will unite
the spare elements and direct the
viewers eye but in the wrong ones
it just might send them into a violent
and uncontrollable rage let's look at
this landing page as an example if you
are both angered and confused
then I've done my job there's so much
color going on it makes it very
difficult to focus let alone understand
what you're supposed to do but for a
website that's a problem I close that
tab in less than three seconds and then
go rage tweet about it into the empty
void of the internet but what if I told
you that with a little work we can
transform this page and these colors
into something of value perhaps even
make them pleasing to the eye
the reason color is so difficult to use
is because it's all about context and
more color doesn't always mean better
color my point is before we go nuts
let's understand how to use all the
colors from our palette in blue how do
we do that Greg I'm glad you asked
let's talk about the 60/30 10 rule think
of it as a recipe for how much of each
color you should use so your primary you
want to use 60% of the time your
secondary 30% and your accent color only
10% like most areas of design there are
well-established rules to help guide
your decision-making this isn't a hard
and fast rule but it's a good place to
start do you like examples I like
examples so here's another one this
poster was designed by my good friend
Paul Rand ok fine we were not friends
but look him up because he's dope and
you'll probably recognize his work he's
got yellow green red blue
and a couple of neutrals all working
together and that's a lot of color so
then how and why do they all work so
well together well let's take a look at
how much of each color he's using I'd
say this is 60% white 25% yellow 10% red
and green maybe 5% blue and black
looking at the colors this way makes a
lot more sense because we can clearly
see how sparingly mr. Rand used each of
the colors so then how do we apply that
to our crazy-looking landing page well
maybe we should start by making our own
color ratio here we have the color
palette for our work-in-progress
landing page now the first step is to
figure out what do we want our primary
secondary and accent colors to be in
this case I'm just gonna go left to
right I'm gonna group some of these
colors together too so because we're
using three very very vibrant colors as
we can already tell using them all
together in big blocks doesn't exactly
work well but most points if you know
what color harmony this is I'm gonna
start by taking these neutrals here and
grouping them together and these are
going to serve as our our primary set of
colors will have blue be the secondary
and then I'm going to group together
this pink and golden yellow and reserve
these four accents okay let's let's make
our own kind of visual color layout here
so I'm gonna grab our primary copy this
down it just so happens that I made this
1000 pixels wide not coincidence that's
because it'll be a lot easier to set up
a sort of visual ratio with a with a
round number like that so if we want our
primary colors to be 60% we just need to
grab this group and then change its
width to 600 because that's sixty
percent of a thousand and we want this
one to be thirty percent so we'll change
the width to 300 lastly we want the
yellow and pink to be the last level ten
percent and that would make them a cool
100 pixels great so on top we have the
color palette itself and in down below
we've got our ratio for how to use each
color
more importantly how much of each color
we're going to use in our layout
now what before we rework our page
there's one more exercise I like to do
to help me understand what colors work
best together and also create some rules
for me to play by real quick I like
rules because they help me make the big
decisions up front and less dumb little
ones later what we're going to do now is
figure out what colors work together and
I like to do that by basing it off the
background color now the reason I have
these four quadrants of color is because
we have our primary which are these
three neutrals in our secondary blue so
when we're approaching our layout
chances are we're gonna have one of
these four be our background color
because in our ratio we're going to see
them the most I like to start just by
placing some type in the layouts here
because when you're using typography you
need to think about a couple of
additional things the main one is
legibility and let's sort of just figure
out big copy color okay so legibility
wise these two are solid this one not so
much
we have a couple options here now we
could go with the ivory just sort of
invert this or the more cream color I
think either those would work Blues on
the table as our secondary color you
know I can read it but depending on
someone's vision or the brightness and
darkness of their screen this this might
be difficult for some people to read so
I would opt for something more legible
I'm gonna keep really simple and just go
with the ivory or both of these now the
other thing to consider is maybe we have
a text link that we need and then also
if we think of these as as links that
sort of opens up the color usage
scenario a little bit alright we know
that this type color over this
background works well it's clear we can
read it great now if it's a link it's a
call to action so we could use an accent
color because that's kind of what we're
reserving these for over white I like
like the pink I think that works really
well you try yellow but that's a bit
hard to read so
let's go with the pink they're over this
cream background yeah for the sake of
legibility I think think works best over
black you know yellow could work pink
could work so I think either of those
are on the table and then over the blue
pink stuff that's that's a really hard
read I don't know that that would work
I'm not sure yellow would work either
it's better let's go with that I think
either yellow or or white and it depends
on the usage if it's like text that's
sort of in line in a paragraph
you know you might might just be fine
using white white type with like an
underline or something but whatever
let's sort of use that as our basis now
the other thing we can do is let's say
we we have a button we want to draw
people's eye to that so what we don't
want to do is make it one of our primary
colors we're gonna see it being used
everywhere else and we're not going to
know that it means something special a
button I think is a great opportunity to
use an accent color I think would
definitely work and I think yellow would
work too either one would work over this
background let's see what we got over
here the yellow kind of gets a little
dull with this background because
they're both kind of warm I think I
think is the way to go down here yep
pink or yellow seems to work and what's
interesting is like the yellow becomes
so much more bright and vibrant like it
works really well it just as well as the
pink in fact and over here yeah this is
tricky this blue is super vibrant I
think the the pink and the blue kind of
vibrate off each other they they're kind
of like fighting for my attention so I
don't think pink is the best choice
there yellow is better it doesn't kind
of vibrate as much so I'm okay with that
basically we're going for contrast we
want to grab someone's attention so I
think either of these might work
cool all right so you know now we may
have some little like design elements
I'll call them just that we sort of you
know use for decoration around things
and this is where we have to be mindful
of our ratio because if we start making
these pink and yellow it's like the sort
of D values are our use of them as
accents because well they become
overused and if we look at our ratio we
can see if we sort of look at this
layout like
very small percentage of this should be
either yellow or pink and we've already
reserved those for these sort of calls
to actions so we want to stick with our
or other kind of like neutrals and maybe
even our secondary color yeah yeah so
this looks good overall and then I think
you know if we had to really really had
to we could always add like a little a
really small design design element here
that's yellow because as long as it's
not taking up a really big space then I
think it's it's okay and you'll notice
I'm trying to keep the yellow away from
the blue so it sort of blends in a
little more with the background so if
I'm looking at all these I feel pretty
good about it I think we have a nice
sort of set of color rules for each
background we seem to be obeying our
sort of ratio of color usage you have
cool little accents that are don't
overpower the main call to action I
think we're in good shape here fan
tastic we prioritize our colors we know
which ones go well together while
keeping our colour ratio intact I think
it's time we take another shot at that
landing page we've got our work cut out
for us but fortunately we are smart and
we made these wonderful color pairings
that we know work and I'm going to use
these as guides to sort of figure out
what I want the background color of each
of these sections to be I'm gonna take
the menu first I think and just sort of
make it kind of kind of neutral that's
fine okay we know pink is an accent
color so we're not gonna use it as a
background let's just sort of mimic what
we did over here so we'll change this to
that ok the type is black I like that
that's good this is our button or sort
of call to action here so I'm gonna make
this pink yeah I think white white text
is where what we want to do with this
button there's a lot to consider with
this illustration because these colors
are all over the place when we're
starting to sort of like lose some
clarity here but let's come back to that
let's let's sort of just break down each
section at a time this type is hard to
read over the blue let's go back to our
colour pairings I'm just gonna use this
one because it's right here and I like
it and we'll sort of put these
experiments to the tests right this is
more decorative it's not really a call
to action so I'm gonna change I want to
change this to blue
and then our call to action is really
it's really this right right here and we
know in this case we have a link or call
to action it should be pink okay cool
so down here ready to start snacking yes
I am so this is like the big called the
actions and what a lot of contrast we
want people to like look at that button
I think this black background would be
the way to go we need to work on this
illustration a little bit but let's sort
of like resist the urge to go into
detail and just take a step back and
look at it as a whole the one thing I
might consider changing is the menu bar
up here because I guess against white
especially it's so high contrast that
might be kind of overbearing so I'm
gonna go with our secondary color and
make this blue this is a really good
start so far so good
now let's tackle those pesky
illustrations I think in this case you
know what we what we want to do is just
sort of simplify the amount of colors
that we're using and really really sort
of pay more attention to our ratio here
because we have a kind of bright pink
button as our call to action I would go
so far as to say is we shouldn't use
pink in the illustration at all let's
really try to simplify it to maybe just
our primary and secondary colors so like
these neutrals in the blue and then
where and if needed a little kind of
touch of yellow peppered throughout so
I'm gonna start just by kind of going
through and cleaning up the colors and
just starting to simplify things
[Music]
already that looks a lot better and you
know I like the this little touch of
yellow we can probably added a few other
places in here as long as we don't
overdo it it'll actually be a nice a
nice little accent that looks pretty
good to me
it works well with everything so it's it
stays within our kind of ratio all right
good work up here let's do the same
thing with our little cupcake not bad
there's a good balance of color a clear
visual hierarchy I mean hey it's a whole
lot better than this thinker seems like
a good time for the recap part of the
video so difficult to use is because
it's all about context that's true me
color is all about context and use it to
your advantage you need to have a
purpose for each color in your palette
6030 ten primary secondary accent if you
develop your own color ratio and set of
rules for how to use them then your
palette will work just about anywhere
and speaking of things that rule did you
know that I teach a course about color
it's true I totally do
you should totally take it we'll talk
about color theory how to build color
palettes using reference and we'll
demystify all this crazy colored magic
we keep talking about visit the
futurecom slash color to learn more
about it and in the meantime like sub
hit the thingy do that other stuff but
don't forget to wash your hands later
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a wrap